and good evening to you nevada is down  to its last two hours of voting in the  general election thank you for joining  us on eight news now at five i'm brian  loftis  and i'm denise valdez now of course this  is a day the whole country  has been waiting for to see who will  lead the u.s for the next four years but  first  a developing situation that's happening  right here in southern nevada a judge  just ruling that some polling places can  now stay open an additional  hour until eight o'clock this after the  trump campaign  and the nevada republican party filed a  lawsuit  to keep some of those polls open that  additional hour  now that suit listed roughly at 22  different polling sites  that actually did open late this morning  because there were a number of technical  difficulties  against some of these polling places  roughly about two dozen now staying open  until eight o'clock we've got a whole  list of those  additional sites on our website for you  at 8newsnow.com